explosions from the crater of Hawaii's
Kilauea volcano could soon throw giant
boulders and ash miles into the air
plumes of smoke are rising from the
volcano's Center scientists say a
massive explosion would shut down air
traffic and put people nearby in danger
Carter Evans is at the Hawaii County
civil defense agency's headquarters in
Hilo Cartaya good morning good morning
the Emergency Operations Center here has
been the hub for disaster response since
the eruption started more than a week
ago but now with the threat of a
volcanic explosion and the ash cloud it
could create they may soon have to
expand their focus scientists are
keeping a close eye on Kilauea and the
levels of molten rock deep inside you
can see the smoke rising from Kilauea
Zane crater we are at the summit of the
volcano right now and geologists think
conditions will be right for a major
explosion within the next few days
experts fear it could blast boulders the
size of refrigerators into the air and
the ash cloud could cover a much greater
area than the current lava flow bigger
materials can be blasted out of the vent
and in the immediate area of the vent it
could be a ballistics of several tons
since last week
lava has been siphoning away from the
volcano's summit breaking through the
ground in a series of more than a dozen
fissures as a result lava levels inside
the volcano's main crater have been
decreasing if more rocks and boulders
fall into the crater it could create a
blockage and pressurized steam as the
lava reaches groundwater levels the
resulting explosion can blast rocks and
ash for miles all indications suggest
that this could happen and that's why
we're taking measures now to be prepared
for a possible steam explosion meanwhile
officials say they've averted a
potential disaster by successfully
removing some 60 thousand gallons of
highly flammable liquid from a now
shuttered geothermal power plant near
the lava fissures is there any other
explosive
they're chemicals on that side that
explosive guest Hawaii County near Harry
Kim obviously you have to work at a
whiskey I believe we do have a rupture
of the pipes that we have to develop a
solid system of timely evacuation Hawaii
has faced this type of situation before
back in 1924 explosions at the top of
Kilauea killed a person and sent ash and
rocks into the air for two weeks
Gayle oh boy thank you very much Carter
Evans reporting from Hawaii